first thing get warm figure out whether
you want to do that on the ERG the bike
or doing some dynamic movements pick a
few different dynamic movements if
that's gonna be your main thing or if
you just want to check off some boxes
for getting in and out of the ranges
you're gonna go to if we're talking
about being in like a CrossFit class or
general lifting try to do like a
thoracic range of motion drill some sort
of trunk stability exercise some sort of
hip motion exercise and then after that
either do some accessory range of motion
drills if you need to such as like those
shoulder ones we discussed or the hip
ones afterwards get into the specific
exercises that you're gonna start to do
for the day do some skill work for a few
minutes get moving fast on it though be
deliberate with it and then get into
what you're doing start training
Sam Spinelli in the building how you
doing man I'm doing fantastic how about
you yeah very good what do you think is
more difficult to control the human body
or Skype when you're trying to record a
podcast oh man I think I'm gonna have to
shift towards Skype today he asked me
before I would've said a different
answer but we have had an absolute
technical nightmare but we've wrangled
it we're here and we're talking so I
want to UM I want to talk about warm-ups
today everyone that's listening even
from the people that don't do sport
anymore they just did PE in school
they'll have had to do some sort of a
warm-up and I don't have a clue really
why I should be doing a warm-up I don't
at the start of every CrossFit class
when I did Thai boxing I was warming up
there I've got programmed warm-ups from
my swim coach if I do swimming or
anything you know you warm up to do I
even kind of like coffee little bit
before I speak on a podcast everything
has that like on-ramp to begin it right
but I don't know where do we start like
why do we warm up why should we do it no
it's a really important question and at
the end of the day whatever comes to any
of these activities were the retiring
about swimming talking on a podcast or
working out we always want to try to
have the best performance we can when we
have a better performance we reduce our
injury risk when we have a better
performance we have better outcomes
they're just the desired outcomes at the
end of the day and warming up regardless
of the activity is gonna help to do that
if you look at pretty much any high
level activity people do this and where
they progress in certain ways and they
build up into the activity so that they
can then perform at their peak when
they're doing the actual activity and if
you don't have that progression into it
then you're just gonna be going from
coal to into it like you have an
increased risk of injury you are gonna
have a poor performance there's just
tons of negative outcomes within I get
it where do we stop I'm gonna do
something let's presume because we could
there could be a million different
warm-ups a million different sports but
I think if we take something like
CrossFit / powerlifting / a run
endurance sort of thing is the broad
spectrum of what we're looking at where
do we start
with that so when it comes to pretty
much any major physical activity there's
gonna be a few through
a few things that we want to ensure that
we can there's basically like three
buckets we can think of and the first
one is gonna be that you legitimately
need to warm up you need to actually get
physically warm and there's a lot of
reasons behind that but at the end of
the day when we have an increase in our
body temperature we actually have a
faster ability to have metabolism occur
so all of our body reactions occur
through metabolism and they're expedited
so they can happen faster when we're
actually physically warm and there's a
lot of chemistry behind that but for
everyone listening
you got to legitimately get warm this
also helps with like nerve conduction
velocity so when we're trying to do
things that require us to be responsive
reactive we want to be able to do that
quickly and that's gonna be dependent
upon how physically warm we are and so
all of these things are very heavily
based upon just the simple fact of you
have to get physically warm I also
fascinating I didn't even know that yeah
and that's one of the reasons why like
you can look at different events where
people relatively don't have to do like
long endurance activities or anything
like that like a high-level 100-meter
sprinter they will spend a very long
time warming up at a very slow gradual
rate so that they get to a very warm
state but they do it where they don't
have to like expend a lot of energy to
do so and for most people it can be as
simple as like doing a few minutes of
jogging skipping rowing whatever you
like or it can be done through other
things that help to achieve other tasks
that we'd want in a warm-up so then when
we get into like the other
characteristics of a good warm-up we're
gonna be looking at other things like
getting your body physically prepared to
go through ranges of motion they're
gonna be going through for the day so
you know if we're talking about running
there's not a really crazy excursion
that we have to go through whereas when
we get into things like weightlifting
CrossFit other lifting sports you can be
going through huge ranges of motion for
a lot of these things and that's where
maybe doing some dynamic warm-up
exercises can be really beneficial and
that also layers on the added benefit of
when you do these dynamic warm-up
exercises they also get you physically
warm so they can be really beneficial
for hitting two aspects of it
the third key thing that we want when we
do a good warm-up is getting physically
prepared neurologically for what we're
about to go into this is where you have
like the idea of study ramped up and
whatever activity you're gonna do so
like if you're gonna be snatching you
shouldn't just go from doing some
bodyweight squats to trying to snatch
135 it's not really a great decision
whereas you know practicing the skill
aspect of doing some sets gradually
working up in weight or if you're gonna
be running gradually building up an
effort that you're gonna be running at
and then getting into the actual
activity so essentially those are like
the three main buckets of a good warm-up
I like it it's cool it seems like
getting warm would probably quite easily
come as a byproduct of the other two and
I'm gonna guess that priming yourself
neurologically would come by potentially
drilling movements empty bar poly bar
you know like hanging from a rig perhaps
or hanging from rings or whatever it
might yeah that sort of stuff would
start to get those neurons firing
exactly no those are the things that I
would call like the essentials not
necessarily what could go into being
like the perfect warm-up but the
essentials of what someone would want to
not screw things up I mean straight off
the bat I have done and there will be
people listening as well loads of times
you're going to gym maybe it's a bit
cold especially in the UK right it
mm-hmm constantly cold go into the gym
and you do some stretches you get the
bar out its overhead maybe you're not
doing class and you just can't go do my
own thing and you do you start your work
it can start your workout without
sweating so I mean there's a good is a
good heuristic that there's a couple of
beads of sweat floating around how hots
hot
that's it bad it is actually a great
question and so that gets into a little
bit more of like what's the actual
activity you're going to do and also the
individuals ability to sway because
there there are people that like don't
easily sweat there are some people that
you know they look at a gym and they
start to sweat so I mean I mean ii camp
and there's a couple of girls in our gym
who managed to come in and the faces
just look totally flawless when the
finish was that me and some of the guys
look like we've been in a fight yeah
yeah so I'm I'm in that first camp where
like if you see me sweating
I've it's pretty rare yeah so for a lot
of people it's kind of tricky to go off
like that simple heuristic of a couple
beads of sweat but if you are if you
feel cold you've not done a sufficient
job and you should be able to like move
around feel feel loose and those are
like some pretty good markers because as
we start to warm up I talked about like
all these different things like
metabolism and one aspect is when we
start to actually get physically warm
our fluids in our muscle tissue and our
blood vessels in our fascia
they start to flow more freely between
each other and it's called this thing
called the viscoelastic properties of
muscles and other tissues and actually
getting physically warm allows that to
happen easier so you should feel looser
just by actually getting physically warm
I get it I get it okay so where do we go
next we know that we need to have our
three buckets we need to be warm we need
to begin to drill some of the movements
and kind of pry myself mechanically
design include does that include like
sort of static stretching to open up
range what about dynamic stretching I
had dr. Quinn Hannah Khan and we he did
his mobility myths and we spoke about
the vibrating foam roller and the
position gun and the one that's got
Wi-Fi connectivity and it's got
bluetooth enabled and plasia Spotify
songs and stuff like that like you know
what do I need yeah I think Quinn and I
are pretty similar lines for anyone that
doesn't know Quinn and our friends and
he was actually a mentor of mine for a
long time so I'm not against static
stretching when we looked into a lot of
the literature on it there's some stuff
that indicates the like if you do a
challenging static stretch and then try
to go into a physical activity that's
very demanding you're gonna have a worst
performance we have some good
information telling us that whereas that
same information is a little bit
challenge because if you do a hard
challenging static stretch but then move
around a little bit more which is what
most people do no one really like
doesn't max effort hamstring stretch and
then tries to immediately go into a max
vertical jump real life that's where the
research came from on this wasn't
there was one that I saw where people
had done an extended quad stretch and
then it was forced production on a quad
extension as well I'm guess that's
precisely the same thing like who does
that
no one does like one minute max ethic
like quad stretch straight into then
using that muscle exactly and so that's
where then we see other studies that
have done like where they do like that
max effort one-minute stretch
I mean if people get up walk around for
a minute and then do the leg extension
and those people actually don't have a
significant drop in performance what do
they get oh that's that's another
important one they don't actually seem
to gain anything so the things is like
people are very perseverating on like
the idea that static stretching is this
like magical thing and unfortunately we
don't really see anything telling us
that like there are some arguments that
static stretching can do a wide range of
different things but in most cases we
can get the same benefit from other
activities and get it easier and better
like you know the simplest thing of
people's static stretch because they
think they're gonna get more range of
motion okay well we actually have to
like some pretty strong research showing
us that lifting weights through a full
range of motion does that but it also
does it better so then it's like okay
well why should i static stretch and
then there's other stuff I'm like okay
well if you static stretch really really
hard it can actually create hypertrophy
it can give you a bigger muscle but it
does it worse than lifting weights and
there's like just all these things of
like I'm not against it if you enjoyed
go for it but most people don't really
enjoy it yeah so I I did an episode
since I did that one with Quinn he was
episode number 12 I think that I did
with him so we've done that nearly two
million downloads since there will be a
lot of people listening who didn't
listen to that episode I will link it in
the show notes below I employ you to go
back and listen to Sam's peer just they
spelled basically everything that you've
ever done as part of a mobility routine
but yeah he um he essentially said that
people use static stretch stack overhead
stretch let's say typically with a poly
bar so they're gonna open up their
shoulders to get into a snatch but his
argument was you can do that by
snatching with the poly bar plus your
movement plus then you can slowly load
up over time we spoke about kind of some
tenuous information about activating the
parasympathetic nervous system and kind
of getting people into their body but
I'm gonna guess again as you've said you
can drill that by moving into the more
mechanical priming aspect is that
correct yeah yeah yeah essentially hey
Quinn remembered man I'm sure Quinn will
be very happy to hear that
no that's where we get into like some of
the challenges of some of the
traditional information of like you know
stretch go for light jogging you're good
to go
it's not inherently wrong but it's maybe
not the best advice either and that's
where I think a lot of the information
is shifted because you know most people
don't have a ton of time to exercise
most people don't have you know if
you're professional athlete and you got
three to four hours do whatever you want
different conversation but you know like
for me I go to the gym like four days a
week
I've got usually like an hour to an hour
and a half I don't got a lot of time to
screw around and I really want to like
maximize what I do I give a [ __ ] about
what I do and so then it's like what can
will give me the best outcomes with the
reasonable investment so for most people
static stretching is pretty low on the
list where is like dynamic movement
actually going in and out of deeper
ranges controlling that motion if you
want to like go into it hold hold a
little bit of a quote-unquote stretch
for a second there's some value in some
of those things I wouldn't ever say like
there's none and for most people they
probably benefit from it because we can
gear different aspects and that's where
some of the conversation would go in
where we move past like the basic levels
of what would be the central components
of warm-up and get into like what might
take you to the next level because we
can do some things where you like if you
are something that's struggling into an
overhead position for a squat or for an
overhead squat or snatch you couldn't do
some lower level different activities
like for instance a thoracic rotation
drill that might allow you to thank it
into an overhead position better we do
have some research showing that going
into higher levels of shoulder flexion
so basically taking my arm above my head
if we proceed it with doing some sort of
thoracic motion drill we can get an
enhanced
motion going overhead so now you
wouldn't necessarily get that by just
snatching so but you could get that
you're doing a dynamic stretch first and
then strip then snatching and that's
where it comes into light the individual
variation that people have and what they
need like for me I can get overhead just
fine but I have a challenge of getting
into a deep squat and so then for me
doing some different things from my hips
makes me be able to be more proficient
when I actually start snatching I get it
yeah it's um first off I'm very jealous
of the fact that you can get into a good
overhead position when they happen I
really loosen up first because I'm not
in that camp but then I can I can
happily sit on my heels right we all
have our classes are mechanical crosses
to bear in our body so yeah I really
like the fact that we're now getting
into a bit more of the nuance of it
right like it's not just black and white
it's not just that you need to do the
movement it's Point Li you know you may
be able to move the needle more by not
just going in and starting to snatch
there might be some things you can do
but they're likely to be a little bit
more specific to your physiology mm-hmm
cool okay so we've got the fact we've
got our three buckets we've got the fact
that there's some nuance in there let's
start to talk about some nitty-gritty
what are in your experience as a
coaching person and online some of the
best overall warm-ups that you can give
people you know if you were to just
structure one we want five minutes on a
bike and this of this and a dynamic and
blah blah you know what what is going to
give people 80% of the benefit broadly
for the movements they're doing exactly
so most the people that I work with are
in a summer position in me they don't
got a ton of time and so then it comes
back into that conversation of what can
I do to get that 80% return with the
investment and for most of those people
it's gonna be I'm gonna pick four to
five different movements that has them
moving through a different range of
motion that they can do relatively
moderate pace and then that will achieve
the first bucket of getting them warm
it'll achieve the second bucket of
getting them through these deeper ranges
it won't necessarily get them primed up
from the neurological standpoint because
we'll get into that in a second but the
other benefit that it does is it it'll
target those limitations that they often
have
so for the majority of people picking
something like a thoracic mobility drill
because most people do generally have a
limitation in their thoracic extension
which is going to impact their shoulder
flexion so if anyone is doing some sort
of exercise with their arms past their
shoulder and going overhead which is
like the majority of people now if
you're doing a strict press push press
incline bench press even like any of
these things having improved shoulder
flexion is gonna be easier from doing
that
so usually we're gonna pick some sort of
like thoracic extension or rotation
drill can you describe for Levites what
that would look like yeah so you could
do like a side-lying windmill so you lay
on your side bring a knee up towards
your chest and then with your top arm
you just make a big windmill I can see
some videos if you'll want in the notes
but that's like a very easy one it's not
very complex but most people instantly
feel better once they do it like you
have someone try to reach overhead lay
down and do it
boom feels way better are you in a side
plank while you're doing that already
just completely prod down the side on
the ground yeah laying flat on your side
yeah yeah then doing like some sort of
hip movement again most people are going
to the gym they're gonna either do like
a full body routine a metcon running
something so it's gonna be realistically
in the majority of cases like a full
body routine so then we're gonna get
that upper body with the sideline thrust
windmill then we can get into a hip
movement so for a lot of people in my
experience people usually will either
struggle with a hip rotation either an
internal or external rotation so like if
you're sitting on a chair right now and
you try to bring your one foot across
your midline or you try to push it out
that's gonna be like internal and
external rotation and people usually
struggle with one or the other and we
can do this drill called a ninety ninety
hip rotation so you're sitting on the
ground and you've got your you've got
one leg in front one leg to your side
kind of like that classic hurdler
stretch but then you have your front leg
bent and then what we do here is we
rotate our hips forward and back and by
doing this we work through internal and
external rotation and if someone
struggles with one then they get the
benefit of also doing another one and so
the front leg is being stretched into
external rotation the rear leg is being
stretched into inter notation we're
actively moving in
out of it and so for most people getting
that allows us to then get into more hip
extension more hip flexion and just like
this super easy one that covers a ton of
stuff so unless I like go through and
find someone has like a specific issue
it's just like an easy one just say like
90% of people are gonna benefit from it
awesome yeah and then usually some sort
of like trunk activation based exercise
so whether it be like a dead bug a side
plank or some sort of more challenging
variation students living it at the
moment he's hearing he's hearing all of
his stuff through now yeah he loves it
and at the end of the day for most
people learning how to create some trunk
tension is really beneficial it's not
like this magical thing but for a lot of
people it's it teaches them how to be
able to create some tension in the trunk
that allows us to be able to move around
it better and a lot of people just
struggle with that so it's an easy thing
so for most people I would pick like
those three as a minimum and then pick
something else usually and then it's
just like cycled through them for six to
twelve reps and repeat for two to three
sets and you know like if that's the
century what I do in my warm-up and I
can usually finish it off in five ish
minutes and now we're going to like my
first exercises and just gradually ramp
up and do some skill work because the
other advantage is when we're doing that
neurological aspect I said most people
are not perfectionists or perfect
technical precision demonstrators and
whatever they're gonna do like if you
are a weightlifter you probably aren't
fantastic at snatching you're probably
okay you're probably not fantastic
you're a runner you're probably not
fantastic at running your fellow K and
so doing like five minutes of some
technical skill work it doesn't have to
be done slow it can actually be done
relatively out of fast pace you're just
trying to be working on improving your
precision with it so that as you get
into your lifting not only you're now
warm not only have you now improved your
neurological efficiency but now
hopefully over time you're gonna be more
technically proficient because the goal
is like when we actually lift or we
actually run you don't think about a lot
you should just be like doing the
activity you're doing
and so hopefully by doing a little bit
of it at the start where you're thinking
and trying to be you know aware of
what's going on you transfer that over
time I like that a lot yeah you totally
right anyone that's doing a CrossFit
class or anything you know like even
just lifting in the gym on your own
dig that guy next to you he's got he's
got three plates on there right why bad
I better I better hurry up I'll get
three I got three plates on [ __ ] he's
put under that he's put another plate
right okay well you know me like
everyone's kind of distracted away from
the integrity of their movement
precision just by and especially you
know you take it to cross it'll be a lot
CrossFit is listening you take it to
that you know it class gets going the
music gets turned up and you're like
it's [ __ ] good after it it's like
dude you've got 15 minutes to establish
a back squat like it's far like you
don't need to hurry up and everyone's
like clattering plates on straightaway
exactly it's real funny cuz like you
know I assume the majority people
listening here aren't freak savages with
like 700-pound back squats and you know
if you are squatting 400 pounds as your
one rep max you shouldn't need more you
shouldn't need 15 minutes to be able to
establish that like you don't need to
rush into it like I can hit a max squat
in a squat just over 500 pounds and I
could get there in like 12 minutes
assuming that I've done a basic level of
a warm-up first and so that's where like
spending some time doing that cuz most
classes and most people working out are
go and go through some level warm so if
you cannot done a good job then you're
ready to start building up and you can
do a little bit of practice work before
rushing into it yeah yeah I get that
so we've spoken about the fact that
we've got our three buckets we've spoken
about the sidelines windmill or anything
else really that's gonna get that
thoracic move in the hurdler stretch
which I know how it looks I hope that
people listening do if not will I'll get
a link off you'll be in the show notes
below if you're a little bit confused
what about cardio is the like should I
not be on an assault bike what about a
rower or a sea - you know like pretty
much all of our warm-ups make us go for
a run or sit on a bike or whatever
before what you thought sir yes so again
it comes back into their like
conversation of how much time do you got
and by no means is that a bad thing it's
just like I would put it as a
we're priority and if someone has the
time I actually coach a bunch of
CrossFitters and so most of them will do
a five-minute thing on either a run an
Aerodyne or AG and they're gonna do that
first then they're gonna get into their
other stuff that I outlined but most
those guys are training for like an hour
and a half to two hours and for them I
think that the the merit is there to do
it and if we're there if they're doing
activities that are more based on those
as well
like if they're doing an ERG workout
we're gonna warm up on the ERG if
they're doing a running workout we're
gonna warm up running but if you're
doing lifting if you're doing a lot of
other things I'm gonna put less of a
priority on that allow you to get warm
through your movement through your
dynamics - yeah all the rest of it okay
cool so the main movement that I see
people struggling with especially in
CrossFit class and I'm like I'm speaking
as patient zero for this is is the
snatch he's getting it oh yeah getting a
barbell overhead getting yourself into
that position especially if like me
people have been a bro for the last ten
years and if just in that chest and
biceps every twice a week so can we talk
about perhaps a some slightly more
specific stuff to help people get into
that good overhead position both lower
and upper oh yeah absolutely man so
again we're gonna be looking at when it
comes to the upper portion we're gonna
want to check off that box to the
thoracic motion it's gonna be really
beneficial for the majority of people
and so that's again like that sideline
windmill or we could get into something
that's very specific so when we're
talking about the snatch
when we take our arms above our head
that's what we call like a thoracic
extended position and there are
different drills that we can do for
instance like a bench t-spine mode so
what happens here is we have a bench
where to the side of it we're gonna put
our elbows on it we're kneeling so
kneeling and you're almost like a prayer
position like you're gonna be praying on
the bench then ideally you have a dowel
in your hands and your palms are facing
you and that way you can then sit back
and it takes you into a shoulder flex
position and that extends your thoracic
spine and then you can bend your elbows
and bring your hands back towards behind
your head
so what this does here is by having our
elbows bent it puts a little bit more
tension on our triceps our triceps cross
our shoulder joint so they can limit how
much shoulder flexion we get so how well
we can bring them overhead by going into
shoulder flexion it helps to encourage
us getting into a thoracic extended
position and then by sitting back
what makes this drill specifically
really great is when we sit back we go
into some posterior pelvic tilt II and
some lumbar flexion so essentially like
our backgrounds a little bit it's
unloaded so it's fine and the benefit
there is that we see that in the
research when we go into a little bit of
lumbar flexion it limits how much motion
occurs at the lower back and encourages
at the upper back so because our goal is
to specifically try and encourage more
upper back motion to get more shoulder
motion this drill just like works
beautifully for that really cool yeah so
that's a great one
and then when we're talking about again
snatching so if everything else is
moving there I drill that's similar to
that but little bit different would be
like a polo for exercise this is one
that actually Quinn is very well known
for but it's essentially where we just
lay on our back and then you can have a
dowel you can have a dumbbell a
kettlebell
I probably not utilize a barbell
specifically for your warmup
but you could and then you just laying
there on your back arms extended out
pointing towards the roof holding
something and then you're gonna lower it
down towards the ground above your head
so you're trying to flex your shoulders
so reaching up above and as you do that
you're trying to reach out trying to
have your shoulders extend out more and
then keep going back and then as we do
that we're just trying to slowly go into
that range and then come back up out of
it now earlier we discussed the
differences between like static
stretching and strengthening and whether
or not this is strengthening different
conversation but it's like resistance
based stretching essentially and so this
is a type of motion if we go really slow
into it that's called eccentric motion
and we've got some good research on
different motions like this showing that
it actually does really well before
exercise to enhance motion and so then
just doing a nice few repetitions slowly
into that rain
and coming back out of it he's gonna
enhance how well you can bring your arms
above your head
is that so if biceps brushing the ears
in that position yeah okay and if would
you advise knees open so feet feet up so
sort of knees are a little bit of an
angle or legs up flat so my preference
would be more towards like the knees up
so if you can think of like that dead
bug position even I bring them up all
that all the way that far because what
that does is it really encourages people
to make sure that they're putting the
motion at their shoulders because one
thing going on too much extension in
that see exactly yeah oh yeah I can see
how that would happen if you like to
route straight
you'd be tight and tight in the hips and
you'd push up through the through the
midline right yeah or if you're tight
through the upper back and shoulders
then you use your lumbar spine to extend
is to get around from having to go
through them that's one of the reasons
like for a lot of people that are maybe
not as competent going overhead you'll
see them extend at their lower back a
lot more that's me that's me all day
that's describing me see me snatch some
okay so we've got we've got ourselves a
mat that I I've just noticed there's
something that I meant to bring up what
about PMF is a replace for PMF and can
you describe what that is yes so for
anyone that doesn't know PMF is a really
fancy term I sort of originally from a
company that like formulated it and it's
called proprioceptive neuromuscular
facilitation and it's nothing special
sorry yeah you know like theoretically
there's a lot of like mechanisms that
they talk about and like it's in you
know physio school to give you like all
these different terminologies to
memorize about PMF the terminologies
make it sound cool and the some of the
stuff in the rash now they say sounds
fantastic when they start talking about
you know reciprocal inhibition all these
different terminologies of the start
throw it at you I want most of most of
the time it's just like that's [ __ ] that
we get when we just lift weights anyways
yeah and it and I think that's like a
really common thing and like the physio
chiropractic and like all the rehab
world is essentially like make things
sound more complicated and that means
that it's actually way better and it's
like a big load of [ __ ]
it's frustrating to me it's it's like
signaling right it's like look at my
technical expertise I'm using this word
which sounds so convoluted I mean you
know you don't need to worry don't worry
about the about the the technical Rhea
duction inhibition or whatever it is
like you don't worry mother like yeah
okay so don't [ __ ] around rupee enough I
don't think we actually describe one
here what what PMF is but it's
essentially putting yourself into a
stretch and then forcing muscle
contraction in that stretch to then
allow yourself to stretch further right
is that close to a description that's
like one one aspect of peanut that's the
hard part is like so people they're like
in the details of PMF it's like a whole
system of structures it'd be like saying
what is CrossFit and you describe a
snail [ __ ] SH I didn't realize that
opened Pandora's boxes is that what the
P and P and F stands for Pandora's
oscillation yeah Pandora's bollocks yeah
okay so no PMF we've just with snatching
we've decided to do our thoracic stretch
we've got down into our preposition
we've got a dowel out we've also made
Quinn happy because we've got ourselves
into a dead book and we've allowed our
hands to come up and over our head like
wonky wonky low dumbbells or like a
dowel or like just so it's super super
light right so yeah like you don't you
don't want to grab a 45 pound bar and
start busting out like 20 kilos is too
much for most people
whereas like you know when I do it I
grab a 10 pound dumbbell or so it'd be
like 4 kilos from those before all the
metric system users I am metric system
so but you still my American friends and
I just lay back bust it out and they're
not good to go
are you sorry just for clarity here are
you having palms facing forward towards
the ceiling or pop-punk icing in towards
the ears yeah so that depends on what
you're holding so if you're holding a
dowel you're gonna have palms facing the
ceiling
for donating you're holding a dumbbell
you're likely gonna be holding it palms
facing each other okay yeah as you get
like more narrow so essentially if
you're grabbing a small dumbbell it's
gonna be a little bit more narrow the
more narrow position while keeping your
palms facing the roof is gonna be more
challenging to hold
and it can be a little irritable to some
people it's one of the reasons why
people have a little bit easier time
like if you lay on your back and you try
and take your arms above your head and
you go into like your snatch grip
position it's easier to hit the floor
then if you go into your jerk grip
position yeah yeah
well you see these um I'm sure you'll
have seen them these videos online if
like these hypermobile papers suny
webster who i'll send this video to one
of my buddies past modern wisdom guest
like he's got videos of him going into
us actually touching the ground with a
barbell overhead and his hands crossed
in like some weird power rangers [ __ ]
it's like yes what week what what is
your like construction honestly i came
so he was on a night out he's in the
living room just through the back there
once after we've been on a night out and
i came in in the morning and he was
stretching you know that people just do
that stretch they put their arms in the
end they do this and you can see my
minor is essentially just lateral with
my body when i put my arms up I promise
you his arms were parallel going
backwards behind him like a bird like a
bird at the top of the flap and I was
thinking this is what happens when you
do weight lifting a high level from at
the age of 10 isn't it yeah absolutely
insane man and he does it under control
like it's just that's what you want okay
so we got that week we've got ourselves
into some good movements there are we
going to lower or is there anything else
we need to do with upper to prep
ourselves roots for a snatch now I think
we're most people they're good to go
like at that point and then when we're
getting to the lower body stuff again
like that 90 90 motion so like somewhat
of that hurdler position that's gonna be
a good starting point and then after
that you know maybe some sort of ankle
motion exercise so similar to the the
shoulder flexion one where we're laying
on our back and then pulling the
dumbbell overhead doing it that's an
eccentric based stretch I think doing
something some of that for the calf is
really beneficial so most people are
gonna struggle with having their knee go
forward and when your knee goes forward
it allows you to stay more upright which
is really beneficial in a snatch it's
really beneficial most activities but
again people struggle with that and
getting some sort of like deeper calf
raise type exercise done first can
usually allow for that like
you set up on the edge of a step and
then you lower down for like three to
four seconds pause for a second on the
bottom and then come back up just like
what we're doing for that overhead one
it's gonna be really beneficial and if
you do it steadily over a long time it's
gonna help to increase that range of
motion get you comfortable able to
control the position too and have a
really good transfer when you start the
snatch mmm is that one foot one leg at a
time or both together the biggest
deterring are therefore one foot versus
two foot I would say is like how strong
the person is because if you can't like
really get out of a one-legged one very
well you're probably just want to do two
feet man a lot of people I think a lot
of people don't realize how weak their
calf's are as like a as a physio who
does a lot of work with different people
like I work with a lot of runners and
triathletes and they come in and I make
them like bust out legitimately good
quality calf raises they're often quite
shocked at how weak they are especially
these people who use them all the time
right yeah yeah and it carves every day
yeah that's interesting okay so we've
got that we've we've got ourselves I
think that's the that I was to do a
survey of what movement do you struggle
with I think snatch might be number one
but why don't we do a couple of bonus
rounds what else sure what else do you
find people coming to you and saying hey
Sam I need a warm-up for this movement
what some of the common the common
requests yeah a deadlift is a pretty
common one and I think like you know
when we're looking at things that are
different from the snatch you know like
a like a squat I'm gonna find you a lot
of similar things as what we just
outline for the snatch similar kind of
requirements clean other than a spur to
the front rack which a lot of people do
struggle with and we could talk about
like getting into the bottom position of
the clean is gonna be similar from the
hip standpoint but there's gonna be a
little bit different aspect for the
front rack and then otherwise the
deadlift is a pretty different one
because we have like a much higher
demand on being able to get deep into
the hips because if you're doing a good
job like you're not squatting the weight
whereas you're gonna be keeping your
legs more extended and then hinging at
the hips to a higher degree and so for a
lot of people that's gonna be like a
different man
so I guess we could jump into either the
front rack or the deadlift with your
feeling I'm feeling let's deadlift first
and then we'll arrive front rack yes
when we're talking about the deadlift
again a couple of the main things that
challenge most people is gonna be that
deep hip flexion position particularly
with the knees extended because
essentially for most people they feel
like they're hampshire's are gonna rip
off and I'm gonna guess sorry to
interject I'm gonna guess what that
causes some people to do is probably
stay too upright at the bottom of a
deadlift right and squat yeah got into
it too much yeah interesting yeah
because I see you know all of the guys
that I know that I've got some friends
Johnny one of the co-hosts of this show
he's dead lifted three or seven in the
105's so yeah it's like he's gone he's
got a regional record up here yeah and
you see the position that he gets into
and he's not squatting the way he's
squatting the way when it's his time to
squat but what he's dead lifting he
doesn't do that exactly that's what you
see with people that are very proficient
at dead lifting it's one of the reasons
why like if you ever watch Sonny as an
example Sonny dead left and how he does
it compared to that guy
it would look probably quite different
it's because Sonny while he's still
strong he's not like a high level dead
lifter he's a hell of a weightlifter and
when weight lifters setup there they're
not looking to maximally deadlift
they're looking to perform a higher
velocity based movement that's gonna set
them up to receive a weight in a
different position so it's just like a
drastically different position but
that's one of the reasons they set up
with like their knees more forward and
more of like a squatting typisch
movement the problem is that if
someone's trying to legitimately deal
with the big weight and be very strong
in that position that's not the position
to do it from mmm I wonder how many
people that do CrossFit perhaps have
started to confuse the mechanics
thinking to me doing it I probably do I
probably think oh well a deadlift just a
hardcore clean with an over-under ground
you know yeah no that's actually a
really common thing yeah definitely
interested okay so what deadlift in I
think you got ourselves into that
position how we good yeah yeah so I
think for a lot of people again starting
off that 90 90 drill just to like clear
off some stuff boom get it done and then
we could get into getting the hamstrings
a little bit more comfortable and
getting into a deep position and so a
good exercise for that is where you have
like a rig or a doorway or something
that's gonna be like firm stay in place
and then you can put your leg against it
and then have your other leg down by the
side so what you're gonna do is you're
gonna lay in your back and you're gonna
put one leg extended up on the rig at
the doorway whatever it is and then
we'll start off having both legs up and
then you're going to lower down the one
leg that's in like the doorway or beside
the rig another one stays in place and
your goal is to be able to lower down
towards the ground while keeping your
leg straight you'll see locked it will
try to bend their leg your goal keep it
straight keep your back pressed into the
ground and let it arch up and then over
time you work closer and closer to
having your butt touch the rig and
having your leg extended so the further
out you are the less hip flex you'll be
in and the more you get close to the rig
the more flex you'll be and the same
with your knee extension so people that
really struggle are gonna be really far
out
heathered knee bent and then people that
are really comfortable with it are gonna
be basically there but against with like
totally straight and then going through
essentially somewhere kind of setup
where you're going down nice and slow
three to four seconds pause in that
bottom position come back up and then
switch sides and do as many times as you
feel the thing here is like if you get
to a point where you're just like
absolutely demolishing it then you can
come off the rig and try and maintain
that leg up that's gonna put a higher
demand on having like trunk oh my god
great exercise great exercise yeah
so I think for a lot of people doing
that 9090 position doing that and then
doing some sort of like lat based
activation exercise so we'd essentially
want some sort of like pullover based
exercise but different then so like when
we did the pullover earlier and we're
talking about the snatch the emphasis
was on getting the shoulders opened up
overhead
whereas now we're looking to come down
and bring the hands by your side as you
do a pullover and so like that same
position doesn't work very well but
instead what we could do is like be
standing a little bit bent over position
have a band out in front of us and then
pull our arms down by our sides so it's
like you're trying to sweep your hands
back by your side have we ruled the
buttons if we loop the band around a
break here or is it literally just
between hands I would loop it around the
rig okay that was brilliant we're just
pulling down and yeah
exactly yeah and doing that is gonna
allow you to get a little bit more lat
activation the lats are really
beneficial and deadlifting whether it be
from the standpoint of being able to
help maintain the bar close to her body
but then also your lats actually have
attachment into your spine and so when
they have a higher level attachment we
can create more stability around the
spine but focusing on driving those
shoulders down towards the ground
exactly yeah yeah yeah for everyone demo
thing don't pull your shoulder blades
back pull them down okay why is that
well so if you think about physics when
we do a deadlift we want to reduce the
range of motion so we want to have to
move the bar as little as we need to and
if you have your arms in place and you
pull your shoulders back it actually
increases the relative length because
now your chest is closer to the ground
and show that move the bar the same
distance whereas if you put your
shoulder blades down it'll relatively
decrease the length that you have to
move and the other benefit is that
actually increases your light activation
whereas pulling them back does not okay
I once got red pills on what low bar
squating means by Johnny and he was
telling me about is it moment for Sam is
I what it's
it's got a moment on yeah moment um yeah
yeah he fully read pilled me one day
about that okay no worries man right
we're gonna either front squat or we're
gonna prep for our clean how we how we
saw in our front rack so I think doing
like a thoracic rotation or extension
drill kinda like those ones we discussed
earlier so either side like windmill or
the bench moba those are two great
options to start off with but then
things get different because we're not
going overhead really and so instead
what a lot of people complain about with
the front rack is having like wrist
discomforts so a lot of people will like
complain grab the wrist it has
bothersome and it's because like at the
end of the day it does require you get a
decent amount of wrist extension the
difference though is that for people
that usually don't complain about it
they usually have pretty good shoulder
external rotation and if you think about
it like when I'm in this position this
is where my arm can set up I have to
really extend my wrist hard back if I
can't rotate outwards very well but if I
can rotate out really well and then I
don't have to extend my wrist as much
that's where if you ever see like a
video of klokov doing a push press or
any kind of position like that the dude
has almost a straight wrist and it's
like his wrist is not extended but he
has like such good external rotation
that he's able to get in that position
be very strong from there bro so it's to
interject this I'm I saw body power 2018
was with the when I first met Sonny
right so two years ago and we're on a
stand with a full rig setup and we're
doing muscle ups and like chilling out
and Sony comes in does a little
it wasn't like booked on it does a
little presentation and clock off walks
by and he sees he sees him doing his
circus lifts in and then he he messes so
Sonny messaged him and was like hey man
like John it should we do something
tomorrow cuz he's got his um clock
off-brand of weights and plates and bars
and stuff and they had a big lifting
platform over there and he just replied
I can't remember what he replied it was
like the most Russian it was like yes
tomorrow strict press and it's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] so you watch clock ops he he put
like I think he jerked 210 from the rack
like just like animal absolute animal
and yeah him and Sonia doing stuff and
there's like a couple of videos floating
around of it that was really cool but
the man I met him said hello said like I
think I really like sort of what you
doing and blah blah
the dude shook my hand and I swear to
god it was like you remember when you
were a kid and used to put on your dad's
slipper pretend to be your dad into his
hand is this room in here I could sell
this as real estate like this genuine
square footage inside of this thing yeah
he's just like an absolute thick beast
everything about him is very thick isn't
it yeah actually I would ask you about
that I want you to ask someone for ages
why does claw Cobb set up with his needs
out so wide in that particular position
so I don't see many weight lifters set
up in that position for the clean Oh in
the clean yeah using the snatch - right
you talking about his bottom position
yeah yeah yeah so it's funny because I
actually set up very similar to clock up
and it's like really common for so I
talk about like these hip rotation
things and for individuals who have a
limited hip internal rotation it's hard
to maintain your your knees directly
forward in front of you because you
don't actually have that internal
rotation and so then if you turn your
feet out turn your knees out it allows
you to get around that and if you know
I've never assessed klokov I can't claim
to have done that but I've watched
thousands of videos if haven't moved you
can just tell in the way that he chooses
to do a lot of things that he inherently
has that same issue it's really common
and a lot of like larger males to have
that limitation and so it's just like a
likely scenario for him and you see that
a lot in a lot of like Russian descended
males where they have like limited hip
internal rotation so then they saw it
that way that's why you see it a lot
across like Ukrainian lifters some
Belarusian lifters all these different
kind of people where they have like that
similar bottom position and they also
squat in this similar way yeah just like
very different from a lot of other
places
I guess girls don't know how good
they've got it with the key shape
pelvis maybe not it's hard to say well
yeah there's benefits and limitations
and all these things right they've got
the pain of childbirth but they've got
the benefit of a deep squat like you
know throughout life so oh yeah plus
these pluses and minuses okay so we've
got we're talking about front rack we've
talked about that external rotation what
we're doing for it
so a good one is gonna be you simple
simple as fantastic especially we're
talking online no one's gonna give it
understand when I give a complicated
exercise so simple thing you're gonna
lay on your back you're gonna have your
elbows up to your side and then you're
gonna try and bring your knuckles to the
ground so you're gonna have arms bent so
you're gonna make like a like a u-shape
and what you're gonna do here is if you
can get your knuckles to the ground okay
you pass that test
nice job now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna put your elbows on top of
something like the edge of a 25 pound
plate a little step-up something that
you can increase the range of motion and
then repeat and then you can hold on to
like a 2.5 pound plate a 5 pound plate
something relatively light that's just
helped to pull you back into that range
sort of like the shoulder flexion
exercise and just slowly go back then
come back out of it and what's that
gonna do is it's gonna pull you in to
shoulder external rotation and you can't
roll back out of it and it'll allow you
to have that extra range so that
hopefully you're able to get into a more
excellent rotated position and less
stress on your wrists got you so for the
people who need a little bit more
clarification there it's like they're
it's the classic double bicep pose from
a from a bodybuilder right and there but
instead of that we've got shoulders are
running in a straight line arms are at
90 degrees then I'm gonna guess as they
go back that that angle maintains that
forearm to upper arm angle maintains as
we go back yeah exactly
cool and then again slow on the
eccentric touching the floor and then
coming back up you just coming back up
to to vertical like as we flow yeah cool
why don't we do is a bonus round how can
I sauce that's my external rotation yeah
how about improving my internal rotation
of my arms what should I be doing for
that
oh I like actually just the opposite
keep going down okay okay it's a very
simple one and it's really effective
especially if the conversation is about
weight lifting because if you think
about snatching or cleaning you're
basically in that exact position you
have an extended torso you send it up
and your arms are right there yeah
exactly and so it's highly specific
which is gonna be really beneficial the
only thing there is that I tell people
that they should take there they should
do one arm at a time and they should
take their non moving arm and they
should put it on the front of their
shoulder and that we can they can feel
as they turn down if their shoulder
starts to pop up like it leaves the
ground then they're not really moving
through their shoulder anymore and they
should stop going down and then come
back up because the emphasis is on like
shoulder motion and so if you're just
getting more motion because like your
shoulder blades moving funky or you're
moving out of your back like that's not
the desire because you don't want that
during the motion so let's just keep it
to what you're looking for and keep it
on the shoulder that movements that you
shaped lying on the ground I'm gonna get
it is that definitely meets our criteria
for 20 percent with a percent of the
benefit right you know you can continue
that down and then go back up and you've
sorted you're in general and external
rotation with one exercise that's pretty
cool
yeah I like it that that's one of the
big winners I'm just thinking about some
of the other things that people might
want to prime for how about um lower
traps how about someone potentially
again like me a little bit of a bro
tight in the upper your abs tight in the
chest that rolled forward classic sort
of bro lifter type posture how can i
prime myself to get back and down so
assuming that you like gone through
these other things that we just
discussed particularly like the thoracic
motion or any of those ones because
those are gonna be really beneficial to
get some thoracic extension but then
after that a nice easy one is where you
know you lay on your stomach so if you
just did the w1 for instance you could
just progress off this or you if it's
not relevant like you're not snatching
anything you just want to get some lower
trap activation for other reasons you
just lay flat on your stomach face down
towards the ground and then you're going
to take your arms so that you make like
a t-shape so your arms are straight out
to your sides and then you're gonna lift
your arms up and you're gonna try
and make like a snow angel motion over
you try to bring your thumbs together
overhead and as you do this your goal is
to keep your chest down on the ground
and that way you have to actively lift
up through your shoulder blades and that
way you're utilizing your lower trap
you're using your rhomboids these other
musculature zuv your upper back that
require you to use scapular motion now
if you're not able to get all the way
overhead
I'm gonna guess like you might struggle
with that just go as far as you can and
then come back down and repeat and you
know like if people are trying to find
this exercise if you google like prone
angels it's a common exercise it's named
for it they can find variations of where
it's shown it's like just lie flat in
your stomach lift your arms up and then
try and bring them a lot of times you
see people like go all the way back down
to their hips and then come back up
overhead and it can be a great way also
just for developing the upper back to
you go kay so we've got palms a flat to
the ground arms are out to the sides
yeah and then we're just gonna take them
up and then we're gonna allow them to
come back down I can fit like that would
that must feel probably quite nice I can
imagine that feels quite it would you
ever if you became quite proficient at
that and then got yourself too overhead
would you then maybe add like a point
two-five play or a point v plate like
into either hand to start progressively
overloading yeah exactly yeah we've got
it
Quinn quit quit mate if you need some
advice from me at any point about how
you need to do your warm-ups or
something just come speak to me exactly
yeah a few tips man I think I think
we've got it you know I think I think
we've managed to create a pretty good
robust warm-up for people so why don't
we why don't we do a recap so that
people know what they're they're going
away with for this week how are they
gonna how are they going to move the
needle this week on their wallet
absolutely so first thing get warm
figure out whether you want to do that
on the ERG the bike or doing some
dynamic movements pick a few different
dynamic movements if that's gonna be
your main thing or if you just want to
check off some boxes for getting in and
out of the ranges you're gonna go to if
we're talking about being in like a
CrossFit class or general lifting try to
do like a thoracic range of motion drill
some sort of trunk stability exercise
some sort of hip motion exercise and
then after that
either do some accessory range-of-motion
drills if you need to such as like those
shoulder ones we discussed or the hip
ones afterwards get into the specific
exercises that you're gonna start to do
for the day do some skill work for a few
minutes get moving fast on it though be
deliberate with it and then get into
what you're doing start training Mon I
love it I like the idea of getting the
warm-up you know really cutting it down
to size you are right as well
everybody's strapped for time now
especially you know in CrossFit class
they'll people like the fact that you
can get in and out ie you know the power
lift is that are listening ice elite you
the fact that you guys go in and haman
and you have to spend because there's
some of the rests that you need you got
to spend you know two hours plus in the
gym but the total tonnage that you've
moved maybe you know but it's not that
much it's just that you've got you
putting yourself into so much stress so
yeah I like it I like it a lot and then
um just as a final thing you know we
talked about some of the specific stuff
for movements is there a way that you
would be able to begin using your
movement or begin doing your movement
let's say I'm gonna start snatching and
then interlace that with some of the
positional stuff or would you have warm
up is warm up and then once warm up is
finished it is lifting or would you then
maybe start trying in this person so
like I'm a big fan of people doing
something active in between their
warm-up sets so like if you are doing
technical skill work or any or just like
light snatching those kinds of things
doing one of the range motion type
exercises in between sets particularly
if it's one that you find really
beneficial to you because then it helps
to ingrain it even better the thing that
I would say is like once you get into
your actual working sets I would like
try to limit that because you want to
legitimately rest if you're trying
really hard so you know like if you are
a sixty kilo snatcher and you find that
like doing that overhead that shoulder
flexion drill is really beneficial do it
up until you get to like 50 kilos and
then shut her down and get into your
working sets man I love it I love it
we've we've made it mine we've gone
through we've got great a great warm-up
I'm super super impressed what
why should people go they want to hustle
you online you've just rebranded kind of
you just changed I couldn't find you on
Instagram YES on Instagram I am dr. Sam
Spinelli I also have accounts of citizen
athletics and III rehab so they can find
me there if they're looking for fitness
based stuff sousou-san athletics is a
great resource lots of stuff YouTube
channel now where we're trying to pump
out high quality content and then you
through rehab if you're looking for
rehab stuff tons of resources there I
love it dude we've done it thank you so
much for your time everything that we've
spoken about will be linked in the show
notes below this episode's awesome like
send it to a friend find a person that
you think fact like they need to know
how to warm up as well send it to them
and yeah Sam I'm gonna have to get you
back home I need to find out find
something else to talk to you about that
thanks for having me on Chris that was
great
[Music]
you